有六年那位的话,在五年记的时候就已经做了黑暗网站,然后你还收入二十万
然后我们省的电视台就算了报答我了
报答我往我之后,我的故事在那个电视上播完之后,一切都发生了变化
怎么去舒服的那些人
没有报答出来之前,他们都不知道的
那报答之后的情况是什么呀
报答我之后,他们就,仍然来你猜读出售
那家你那个五年纪,怎么年入二十万的电视台,跟我们好好的就系列了
其实很多人会认为说,在小时五年纪去学习网站,去做一个晚上是一个
是一个让人觉得很不可思议的这个事情
因为当时其实我跟很多的同学一样都喜欢打游戏
然后就给我上完
但是我在这个或者当中,突然间有一天发现我的Q号被盗了
然后我当然就产生很大的一货,就是我的账号
我记得用电脑,为什么我的账号,Q号会被盗呢
所以其实我当时就开始去各种黑暗戴,去搜索各种
往往上吃的晚安,还没去学习
然后在这中间其实还有一次被骗钱的经历
就比如说,大家是我想了学黑暑技术,让他说,你带我回事,你给我赴两百块钱
我就成立你的师傅
然后我就给他转了两百块钱,结果就被骗了
骗了之后,我就在那天黑暑晚,当中就继续学,如何去刀号
结果突然有一天,我自己把我记得张号给盗了
那个时候我就觉得这个世界为我开起了一上门,我居然知道这你们的逻辑是什么样的
那你有了一点点小小的成就感觉后,就会更生存次的学习
比如说我还会去学习,如何去破解它的软件
很多说费的软件是如何破解的,去入侵各种各样的晚占
所以当时我就周一到周五就好好地也没好好地学习,就学习
然后呢,可能下课之后我就开始上网
上网之后呢,然后到了周六周日,就全天就在家里,就去学习这网上去的知识
所以我当时我就为了验证我的这个技术,特别的厉害
我呢,就去找这晚的漏洞,找完之后我就批谈了入侵了一波的晚上
然后把他们的主页修改成黑暑地国的种动画一面
然后并留下我的,你趁插插插,导辞游,你的移车叫插插插插插插插插,导辞游,然后并留下我的教绘的可以有请
这些东西都在网所的,就是自己五年级的时候
对,就是五年级就刚好,因为学习不好,就去了,就去就开学了
三个月自己摸另外一条出路
因为刚才我也说,我家庭还你不太好
用了多少时间,就是从发现被导导自己开始
成为一个月,一个月,就我其实,因为我觉得
所有的少年黑客,它实际上是一个标签
我一直不认为我是黑客
我只是对这种网络来技术,当时是比较愿意去追求
所以那其实我能够给一些同意人吧,或者一些小伙伴一个
一个建议就是实际上你想要去做这个事情,跟你的职业,跟你的经历跟你的背景
没有任何的关系,只要你对它热爱,你就有机会能够把它完成
所以我能不能理解,你当时一段的个问题就是我的客号怎么被盗了
然后你开始自己解决这个问题,用了一个个时间
然后通过自学,把这个问题,那么从你的客号被盗
然后开始自学一直到你购建第一个网站,中间化了中央时间
一年吧,一年的时间
也就是六年纪的时候,开始
就六年纪毕业,六年纪毕业的时候,开始
好,就够问题来了,为什么要购建这个网站?
因为最开始是我周边的同学的账号经常被盗
我把它找回账号,第二是我们周边的职业领区,在一边电脑就老坏
老坏人都是我把它去修理电脑
所以当时我就能生了一个意识,什么呢?
就是我觉得我做一个小学五、六年纪的小学生都会遇到这样的问题
那在于,那在十几年前,这些中国的网民也同样会遇到这样的问题
那我当时就应该去建立一个这样的网站,去帮助大家去
我及这种网络权的支持,所以当时就很简单的一个想法,就建立了这个这样的一个东西
然后就开始了,这个网站是自己做的
这网站说实话是二次开发的
因为对于我来说,其实我觉得,我不需要去证明说我自己
就是从力道一去建立一个这样网站,证明我的机会有动的扭力
我最核心的点是为了去解决,但是中国网民对于网络权异,意识得被博弱的问题
因为当时就用Discasse对,我也是在这样的
当时用的是Discasse,所以我当然经常去证讯的时候,就先去实戏也是Discasse的团队
当时老板还多很熟,很熟的意思
对对对
三个八零后,是吧
当时李小,猫四个四个,对
郁内伙伴之后,应该已经离开了,是臣老臣才待在网站
臣老臣,我臣秘买了
那你拿了一个离子看的自己,待在网站
对,我当就自己做的,二子开发吧
所有的模板,所有的一些插劲亚都进行
当时那个网站是站在哪
在服务欺诚
对,我让你那个服务欺的自己的家人的国体
那不是不是不是不是,是在我之前,用这花了一百个花钱之一
买了一个遇名的一个服务欺诚
拿了一名,要买了个服务欺诚
但是你的地址,去你的空间,对对对
就得特别想了一个空间,那后面量就很大了
那就很大了,我们就找贪住,我就就快原车了
当时你的跑,我来往非常大,你就到那了
量不大,但是内容
就存在了,对对,你出去互表大
内容我觉得在实际年轻,可能也道不老公
而且你往往全还是个比较垂的一个海盐
正好,这个问题都非常好
你正好干的,干嘛这样,你刚开始还没人帮你
就一个人,是吧,来,这个内容是怎么来的
内容当时我就找了一波大学生
你刚开始就找了一波大学生
没有,就是他那种是
这个内容封会两种,一种是我寄原创
就是会去写
但是你要知道一个人的这种效率的生产
你是有现男的,你可能能复在当个的一个办法
我后面就当努得去,就不让去挖人嘛
你就把自己当着一个企业的老板
去看看,你就去挖一些,你觉得
那别厉害的人能给你去不去短板的人
是挖了一波的这些大学生
先说,最开始
最开始你自己怎么遇应的
最开始我就自己
就做了一条内容,每天以前
基本上是,然后再往上走
就是自己原创造转载
转载就是别人的文章,转载不载
因为我觉得其实你坐完上早期,就是你要先把这个量给不下来
让整个的这个产品或者整个的晚上会更加的分满
对,但你这个量做起来之后
有用乎陆虚进来了,你再去追求
是
就是大概的同样时间,就是从
你自己开始做,到找人开始
来一块来做的,这个中间
两个月到三个月,两个三个月
那时候你每天都在行吗?
我每天都在弄载上队
每天都在行
我当时其实有时候会到凌晨两三点的睡觉
第一天工作大概都要注意
一天我觉得我,我呢,就除了睡在我都在工作吧
负业时的学习
主要在这座晚上负业在学习
每天就有文章,他喜欢他喜欢他
完全是,你还得要去推幻他
这晚上你坐得好,就你还得寫一些
特别小的,叫寄导寄巧
然后那边,你看就能学会的
我到后就陆地,很简单吗?
对吧,一看,你可能五分钟十分钟
你就能把这个照片给看完
看完,这里面就留你的这个地
那个晚上的立机,让大家就过来
同时呢,你还要跟同行人去交流
对吧,他们的晚上这个是怎么做的
有点些比赵,比赵历害的能够
来流量来用户的,这些方法
然后跟人家同行人去交流
这为了拿一个大晚上的一个有情变机
来,细点,怎么获得流量?
我们这可是收拌手叫鞋号
就是我觉得我原来的整个的方法
我觉得是比较碎点画的
因为我们当然没有这样的,这种比较结果画的
这就是
所以呢,基本上都通过这种大的晚上去移流
究竟我们让发得上
我发视频叫成,就你就入入那个你的桌面
然后你就跟他说,就是当时很传统的
但是也不用什么运说话
就是你就打一个TLSC的文宅
打开,然后今天那个欢迎大家来到什么什么
然后呢,我是,然后我叫车车车
然后我的晚上,同时什么大哥
中国就晚上去联系到我
那今天我叫到大家的是如何
领机主到号,对吧
然后呢,然后呢,就
其实现在有个新冠公路号的事
对,对
我相信是来了,有个运动软件
对,对,运动软件,这叫什么骂的
可以吧,可以吧,可以吧,可以吧,最开始就这么看的
基本其实他也是一个教学吗,对对
就是你,你不能够把这个事,你做得很重,对
你就让别人先,先轻量的先体验
大家有,有成就感啊
先让他完成一个小目标
当你有了这样的成就感觉,你就会很努力去学习
就跟我最开始学,到号也一样啊
对吧,我第一次我先到号,到完了,成了
成了之后呢,我就觉得
我太理议了,太理害了,我没有做号,我做了事情,我就在晚上做
就叫妈妈的循序奸径,这些大游戏也一样的
是,当时你就出一
六年纪,六年纪,然后每天工作是这个小时
差不多,除了睡觉吧,一天入几个睡频,差不多
一天入不了,一个视频,我们可能几天才入这个视频
然后发个个网站,就是几个头部的网站,我都发过,我都会给他们头膏
都那些
在我黑客动画吧
现在应该没有了
黑客基地
这玩家应该还有
黑暗
老板被抓了
我拿着交换连接就跟他交换
因为
这个算不得了
就不能想说他打他
跟他有意思
然后人来了
那个时候你的基础人来了多少了
就是
在你开的招人的时候
基础人来了一个
招人
大概一天的我有
小姐钱蛮两张钱
一天有两张钱啊
有位有两三千
这他们访问的人
很稳定的
六年提的时候
对
我们后面被电视台报道一天的都有三千一万
一万多吧一样是
先先一点来
一点八
八起那个
来
低护了八出来
说一样还怕呀
怎么去
说服的那些
比如说你就是那个基础很厉害的
你是因为
假讯你现在是因为
20岁
独大一大二的一个大学生的
你呢其实现在在朋友里的学晚晚圈的支持
那时候
那其实我觉得老师交的结婚
举线呢对
所以呢其实我觉得晚晚圈这个东西出了
那个
这是理论以外更多是时间吗
所以呢很多这些大学生他就会在晚上去输出内容
只研究
大学呢他也年轻啊年轻人就年轻轻胜
那我也年轻胜
我就把他当作一个
这个你如何去招援工
招呼类的逻辑是一样的
所以呢我就
先加的他
而且我是属于挂杀网的那个种
因为你有时候加了一些人人人家是
不会拿了你的
所以呢当时就
加了一部分的人
加完之后呢就跟他聊嘛
然后说我现在是一名然后我是临端窮的这个战
那个战争我也不透露我临地多大我就是这个战争
然后我也希望能够多那个交流我看到你在
那个迫集论坂上发了好多球门性的文章
但是呢你现在
对吧你你你就出了发发文章以外你得不到别的这个东西
你算过来拉我这里
我就立马给你一个
房主
然后你就可以在这个行业在这个圈子里建立琴的影响力
你就可以建立琴的影响力
而且我们这网站虽然刚才做没几个月
但是整个的数据流量包括你看到我
个人在这些
大的一个网站本当中发了很多的这些校长的
我觉得我觉得我们这个时候特别有希望
对大伙就需要你家的人才
然后你可以换你的这个时间的加入进来然后那明天我们
我们不敢别的我们就做技术交流就好我们就期望我们的技术能够
交流完整你们共同的成长
然后你愿意吗
然后有的人愿意有的人不愿意的人我就给他多慢慢的新来讲
你当时新来的都很
新来也没断了吗不倒习个人吧
但是但他们的程度都很高
因为他们真的就是一堆就是非安发电脑电脑
他真的是喜欢技术
对他们很就你能想到就是我是想不到的
他能够把他的生活费供建出几百块钱
买QB然后能在我们
论场里面去做那种大楼的活动
就希望我们能够把这个数据要活有多碗
就提升得更高
然后他有时候还帝帝没事我就觉得这个时候我们能成
那我姑娘先前处了给你
他都可以生给做了
对方就包括现在其实还有一个人我们还在联系呢
对就他现在也在一家安全的公司什么时候开始绝对
靠他赚钱
我就开始觉得如果我们只做成功业就比较难
我们还是希望能够去
去获得一笔收入能够让自己走得更远吗
所以能大概就是就是被新闻报道之后吧
多少时间以后
我来想一下
但是11月12月被新闻报道被新闻报道
之后的